in this video you're gonna learn how to
find the remaining factors of a
polynomial when you're given one of the
factors so let's dive into this problem
we've got f of x equals x cubed plus
five x squared plus two X minus eight
and they're telling us that X plus two
is a factor what does that mean
X plus two is a factor it means that
this will divide in evenly into this
polynomial without any remainder now
when the factor divides into a
polynomial but not any remainder that
means that if you were to set this equal
to zero
okay X plus 2 equal to 0 you get x
equals negative 2 negative 2 is a zero
what that means is it's gonna cross the
x-axis when you graph this polynomial at
negative 2 now when you do the synthetic
division if your factor is x plus 2 well
we're here you're gonna put negative 2
if it was X minus 2 then you would put
positive 2 so it's like the opposite
sign or you can think of it as you know
putting a zero in here so now when we do
this synthetic division we're going to
use the coefficients 1 X cubed 5 x
squared 2x and negative 8 keep in mind
if you're missing any of the terms like
if I went from X cubed 2x to the first
and I skipped over x squared I have to
have to put a zero there as a
placeholder so you want to go in
descending order you always drop down
that first number you multiply on the
diagonal and you add straight down you
multiply on the diagonal and you add
straight down multiply on the diagonal
add straight down this last one is a
remainder in this case there's zero
remainder which is what we expected
because we knew that X plus 2 is a
factor and when you do the synthetic
division you go down by one degree so
you go from X cubed down to x squared
and descending order now what we can do
is we can factor this further we can say
what two numbers multiply to negative 4
would add to positive 3 that's going to
be positive 4 and negative 1 to see for
X and negative 1 X adds up to 3x 4 times
negative 1 is negative 4 and we get our
x squared back so these are our
remaining factors X plus 4 and X minus 1
if you want to write the complete linear
factorization we can then add on X plus
2 here so if you were to multiply all
this together we'd get back that
original polynomial if you wanted to
graph it now
by setting all these factors equal to 0
you get the zeroes or the x-intercepts
so we know it's going to cross that
negative 2 negative 4 and positive 1 we
know the leading coefficient is positive
so it's going to go up to the right we
know it's an odd degree it's 3 so it's
going to go the opposite way to the left
all these zeros occurred only once and
you can get a good sketch of your
polynomial function now if you want to
learn more about how to graph polynomial
functions and using the rational root
theorem and synthetic division and kind
of like put it all together you can
follow me over that video right there
where I dive into more examples like
these I'll see you in that video